bonsoir un verdict sans surprise dans le
procès de patrick tissier les jurés
l'ont condamné à la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité
il a été reconnu coupable du viol et du
meurtre de la petite karine dans le
passé et patrick tissier avait déjà été
condamné à deux reprises aux assises
aujourd'hui à l'énoncé de sa peine il
est resté impassible reportage lors anne
berrou et jean christophe duclos
commentaire car in china pour karine je
suis le dernier des derniers étonnement
dans la salle patrick tissier a donc
exprimé des regrets mais le verdict lui
est sans surprise après une heure et
demie de délibérations les jurés se
prononce pour la peine maximale la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
assortie d'une période de sûreté de 30
ans la moindre des choses selon le père
de karine qui ne croient pas à ces
regrets c'est pas possible qu'ils aient
regrets parce que tout le procès n'a
jamais eu un regard jade une larme est
ce que c'est une alarme c'est à mon avis
non
il a au aucun regret la seule solution
c'était l'élimination de patrick tissier
compte tenu de ce qu'il avait fait et de
ce qu'il est encore capable de faire
car c'est sans broncher que l'homme a
retracé le meurtre de la fillette sans
émotion encore qu'il a décrit celui de
conchita l'ema et la tentative
d'étranglement de marie-josée goze
pervers sadique ont diagnostiqué les
psychiatres une personnalité demeurait
opaque des plans la défense on s'est pas
posé la question de savoir quelle était
la cause des actes que monsieur ici a
commise on a analysé simplement les
conséquences au tout au long de ce
procès j'ai indiqué à la cour d'assises
qu'il y avait différentes explications
différentes pistes que l'on pouvait
envisager la génétique d'abord il est
certain que comme l'a dit villanova
c'est un monstre et pourquoi est-il un
monstre mais ce soir c'est sûr après 25
ans déjà passés derrière les barreaux ce
multirécidiviste va y retourner au moins
jusqu'en 2028